une abstention qui se situe entre 66 5 %
et 68 vient de me 6% c'est donc un
record sous la vème république gérald
darmanin le ministre de l'intérieur a
jugé le niveau de l'abstention je cite
particulièrement préoccupante
gabriella talent le porte parole du
gouvernement lui a jugé cette abstention
abyssal en partie lié à la crise
sanitaire sait ce qu'il dit alexis
poulain vous êtes d'accord avec le
porte-parole du gouvernement
absolument pas c'est une excuses
fallacieuses
la réalité c'est que aujourd'hui si deux
français sur trois ne se sont pas
déplacés c'est un acte politique ce
n'est pas par peur d'un virus ou parce
qu la crise sanitaire il ya d'abord il
ya le fait que les gouvernements étaient
incapables d'organiser ces élections on
va sans doute en parler mais n'est ce
pas la direction le fait que les propre
à la propagande dans le matériel de
propagande électorale c'est à dire les
professions de foi et les bulletins
n'ont pas été distribués par toucher
tout le monde
la deuxième chose c'est qu'il ya eu
aucune communication autour de ces
élections donc peu de français étaient
au courant finalement qu'il y avait des
élections départementales et régionales
et puis la troisième chose c'est que les
français en ont marre de ce jeu ou
systématiquement leurs voix et volé par
des partis minoritaires
donc aujourd'hui l'abstention elle est
la star
elle est là la gagnante de ces élections
pourquoi parce que les français ne
veulent plus de ce scrutin à deux tours
majoritaire qui est en réalité une
négation de leur vote est donc
aujourd'hui ce qu'il faut entendre c'est
pas simplement de dire les français
n'ont pas voté parce que il ya le virus
non les français n'ont pas voté parce
qu'ils n'en peuvent plus de ce système
qui est une spoliation de leurs voix
systématique les partis minoritaires
devienne majoritaire parce qu'un
français sur trois va voter mais enfin
c'est quoi ça c'est pas une démocratie
défaillante ce n'est même pas une
démocratie
c'est un simulacre d'élection donc si
les français ne vont plus voter c'est
pour dire je ne veux plus voter dans des
conditions pareilles
pourquoi aujourd'hui encore une fois la
majorité est incapable de mettre une
dose de proportionnelle
à chaque fois c'est la même chose les
conditions ne sont pas réunies m'enfin
on se moque de qui ils savent très bien
que si la proportionnelle arrive alors
ils perdent le pouvoir c'est simplement
ça aujourd'hui quand je dis ils se
parlent de la majorité actuelle
donc ça continue avec déclics finalement
kiki qui partent avec des prime aux
sortants des primes finalement là
en pagne la plus visible médiatiquement
mais en réalité la démocratie est bien
loin et les gilets jaunes sont passés
par là quand ils demandaient la
démocratie directe
le référendum d'initiative citoyenne une
démocratie fonctionnelle vivante
on a là une démocratie morte finalement
on est en phase terminale de la vème
république et on fait comme si tout
allait bien ce qui me moreau hors de moi
c'est quand j'entends par exemple
d'autres étaient réalistes comme
christophe barbier dire qu'il faudrait
rendre le vote obligatoire et que si les
français ne votent et aux régionales il
n'aurait pas le droit de voter aux
présidentielles mais c'est scandaleux
d'entendre des propos pareils c'est pas
le vote qu'il faut rendre obligatoire
c'est la proportionnelle qu'il faut
rendre obligatoire ce qu'il faut rendre
à chaque français le pouvoir
son droit de vote le fait que sa voix va
compter aujourd'hui la réalité c'est
qu'un français qui votent ils votent
dans le vide parce que ce système fait
que sa voix est effacée au profit de
partis minoritaires
donc aujourd'hui pour moi cette
abstention elle est politique elle n'est
certainement pas dû ni au virus ni à un
désamour de l'offre politique non elle
est liée
finalement un désamour d'un régime
politique qui aujourd'hui est une
négation démocratique